brain [ __ ] a minimal esoteric
programming language designed to make
your brain hurt it's turing complete but
not designed to build actual software
it's more like a work of art that
challenges the status quo it was created
in 1993 by swiss physics student urban
mueller where the goal was to create a
language with the smallest possible
compiler it was built for the amiga 2.0
operating system and the compiler weighs
in at under 200 bytes a brain program
starts with a 30 000 byte one
dimensional array all values are
initialized to zero then it provides a
movable pointer that you can manipulate
with eight different commands use angle
brackets to move the pointer left or
right by one cell at a time then
increment or decrement the value in a
cell using plus or minus use a period to
output the byte at the pointer's current
location or use a comma to accept input
and store it at the pointer's current
location and finally use opening and
closing brackets to create a loop notice
how brain fog doesn't require silly
things like variables functions and
classes to get started with brain [ __ ]
delete your operating system and install
amiga os then create a file ending in bf
which stands for brain fog any
characters that are not the aid i
mentioned previously will be ignored as
a comment at this point we have an array
with thirty thousand eight bit numbers
all set to 0. to say hi mom we'll need
to set each number to its corresponding
ascii character we can increment the
first cell then enter a loop with an
opening bracket for each iteration of
the loop we'll decrement that current
cell by 5 then use an angle bracket to
move one cell to the right we'll
increment that cell by three then move
back to the left and close the loop the
loop will continue until the original
cell goes back to zero at which point it
will exit we now have a value of 103 at
index one we can move the pointer to it
increment it to 104 then use a period to
output it that corresponds to the letter
h and ascii we can increment it again to
get 105 which corresponds to the letter
i now we continue this process of
manipulating memory like caveman until
we output all the characters that we
need now to run your code use
right-click copy and paste it into one
of the many online interpreters
congratulations you just said hi to your
mom and brain [ __ ] this has been brain
[ __ ] in 100 seconds if you want to see
more brain [ __ ] content on this channel
make sure to hit the like button and
subscribe thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one